God like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The
God Who reaches down to unworthy
people.
Well, good morning church. If you are new here,
we're thankful that you would take a step to gather with us and
really a step of Faith to show up at
a new place. We'd love to get to meet you. So please let us know who you
are. You can come and introduce yourself to one of us or you
can use that card or the QR code right in front of you and just
to let us know you're here so we can get to know you and how we
can care for you and love you as best. We can
that's our desire today. We're continuing through
our journey in the Book of Micah in
the Old Testament finishing up chapter six today. And so
take your copy of God's word and turn there with me Micah chapter
six and we'll be verses 9 through
16.
In chapter 6 now before we get into it today.
I want to say upfront. This is a tough passage. It's heavy.
But it's always amazing to me as as I watch God
work all of this out because I had planned these
series of sermons for months ago.
And what today was going to be this passage, but
then also we have the Lord's Supper that we do just every few
weeks and it kind of happens to all go together today
and it's really just amazing to watch you'll see what I mean as
you go in this but just it's fun to be a part of what
God's doing.
but as we get into it today and kids this might be
really easy for you to do but I want us all
to think back to those times in our lives when we were kids and
we went through growth spurts, right, you know, I'm talking about and
and so think about that as you went through that season
where your bones and your muscles were lengthening your you're
getting taller your outgrowing pants
and like a week, you know, those kind of things as you're growing
through these growth spurts, but one of the other signs of a growth
spurt is that you're always hungry
You remember how that was when you were a kid, you're always hungry and you're
eating like 30 minutes after lunch because
you're hungry already and my mom. I don't know where this came from.
She asked if I had a Hollow Leg for a while. Not sure what that means. But maybe
your mom did the same.
Where you're just burning through cereal boxes, it just seems like that's all
you're eating and four hamburgers at lunch and it's just
the way it is burning through your bank account really if you're trying to feed a
teenager in that way.
But as a growing child, you never feel satisfied.
You never can eat enough to fill that pit. That
is just seeming to be bottomless.
Well in reality sadly a lot
of people are walking around with the same
feeling spiritually.
See we are constantly searching for ways to
fill a void inside of us.
That we so often turn to substances or
to sex or to wealth or to
travel or to pornography or or
to whatever else it is. We're trying to fill this void. We're
trying to fulfill this hunger this this
satisfaction desire we have in our souls. We're trying
to fill it with all of these things.
yet most people as I've just indicated look
for that kind of satisfaction that fulfillment in everything
but the Lord
We look in all these other places for that kind of
fulfillment.
And hear me, even we as Christians can do that.
Now as Christians we might overlay of a spiritual veneer
over those things and we think we're saying the
right things and we we look one way but inside of us,
we're still searching when you really drill down to
the core we're searching for satisfaction in
the same way that most unbelievers out. There are searching for
it.
For constantly searching for more or better or higher or
faster and we're looking for that to satisfy
us.
And so what we all need to see today.
Is the truth that Augustine wrote 1500 years
ago.
Something he said to God. He said you have made us
for yourself, and we will not find
rest until we find rest in you.
Augustine understood
As he prayed this to God you have made us for yourself God
and we will not find rest until we
find rest in you.
And we'll see that today in Micah 6.
verses 9 through 16
The voice of the Lord Christ to the city it is
sound wisdom to fear your name.
Here of the rod and if him who appointed it.
Can I forget any longer the treasures of wickedness In The House of the
wicked?
And the scant measure that is a cursed.
Shall I acquit the man with Wicked scales and with a
bag of deceitful weights?
Your rich men are full of violence. You're inhabitants speak lies
their tongue is deceitful in their mouth.
Therefore this is God speaking. I strike you with
a grievous blow.
Making you desolate because of your sins.
You shall eat but not be satisfied. There should be
hunger within you.
You shall put away but not preserve and what
you preserve. I'll give to the sword you shall sow but
not reap you shall tread olives, but not anoint yours
with oil you shall tread grapes, but not drink wine.
For you have kept the statutes of Omri.
And all the works of the House of Ahab and you've walked
in their counsels.
That I may make you a desolation and your inhabitants
a hissing meaningless a scorn. So you
shall bear the scorn of my people.
God we look at this text and we see such heaviness we
see judgment. So I pray you show us
today what you want us to see about us even
How you spoke to them how you saw them and how
we can learn from that?
Convict us where we need it.
And may we find our satisfaction arrest in
you alone?
In Jesus name we pray help us.
amen
And so remember where we landed last week where we had God bringing
a legal case against his people because they
had abandoned the Covenant. They had forgotten his
grace they'd live by their own standard. They said we're going
to do it our way.
They thought they were okay though, because they had the temple
in their neighborhood. They thought that they were they were
doing all the religious rituals. They needed to do to appease God
they assumed they supposed to be doing these things. And so they're
like we're okay, right God
But God said no.
Instead you ought to be living according to my standard and that was
the standard he gave in Micah six eight where he says you need to be acting justly
you need to love faithfulness and need
to walk humbly with your God.
And so he brought this case to them and saying you have not done this
and the results of that are here in 9 through 16.
So the the indictments been brought now we see here's
the Judgment. Here's what God is going to bring on them
for abandoning. His Covenant for abandoning
God's standard.
That's what he was showing them here is that guys you have abandoned my
standard and hears. What happens when
you do that? Here's what happens when you take Micah 6:8
throw it in the garbage when you say I don't want
to I don't want to take your requirement God. I
want to take my own way, and I'm going to live this direction.
Well, God says here's what's going to happen.
Here's what happens when you abandon God's standard.
First thing he says is that we end up
following the foolishness of idols.
When we set God standard aside, we follow the
foolishness of idols.
Now this happened all over the book of Mike already, right? We've seen this over and over.
It's actually one of the main themes of the prophets in the Old Testament.
talking about idolatry
but specifically here Micah is referring to what we find
in the first half of verse 16 where he talks
about keeping the statutes of Omri following the works of Ahab. He's
referencing what their idolatry actually is. And
so what he's doing here, this is interesting these two names.
He says, he's comparing Judah remember
the southern Kingdom
He's comparing them to the Northern Kingdom of Israel that had
had these two of its
most wicked Kings of Omri and Ahab.
And so what he's saying to them is hey, remember Armory remember that
guy?
He led the people more than anybody else towards idolatry.
But then his son Ahab was even worse.
Because Ahab actually built a temple built an altar to
false gods. He married a foreign woman named
Jezebel who brought all these other prophets with her from
another nation, and then they had all the true prophets of
God killed.
He's like, hey remember those guys, of course, they would
of course Judah would know who they were. And so Micah says
the people of Judah are keeping the rules of
Omri. They're following all the
works of Ahab. What he's accusing them of
is the same kind of brutal idolatry.
He says guys you're no different.
Judah you are no different.
It's all over Micah.
That these people who are supposedly gods.
Had turned away from him.
Had turned away from his Covenant and they were seeking their
peace and their joy and all of the other stuff the world
could offer.
He says they should have feared God's name and followed the
one who would not lead them to foolishness. But instead they follow these
false gods these idols and that would lead them towards.
foolishness
and so from our perspective this far back this far
forward into we're looking back on them. We can think
well, of course, they were idolaters they had statues and
they had these things but we need to ask the question.
How do we follow Idols today?
Like what are Idols in our lives today?
Well, the definition of an idol is anything that takes the
rightful place of God in your heart.
It becomes ultimate in your heart over God we
try to find life in it. Try to find your peace and
joy in that thing, whatever it may be and so
you think about that implication. It can be all kinds of
things even good things.
It could be your sports team that you either play on or
cheer for.
It could be your kids activities become your Idol.
vocational success
A relationship that you have or or peer approval from
others that you were searching for
life in or political power you want this
or that even the Love of Money can turn
into an idol?
As first Timothy 6 verses 9 and 10
says he says Those Who desire to be rich fall into
temptation into a snare into many
senseless and harmful desires that plunge people into ruin
and destruction.
For the Love of Money is a root of
all kinds of evils.
It is through this craving that's hunger,
right it is through this trying to
fill this hole with money that some have wandered away
from the faith.
and pierced themselves with many pangs
The point here is that trying to fill this void this
hunger in our souls with anything, but the
Lord will only lead to destruction.
It's going to be fickle. It's going to be an unsustainable
foundation in your life. It's going to lead
to foolishness.
We turn away from the Lord's standard we lead to foolishness, but
we also see something in Micah 6.
verses 10 through 12 we turn away from the Lord like Judah
was doing
we we much more easily get to the point where we start to
deceive others.
We follow Idols, but then we start to deceive
others in our lives.
When you look at those three verses 10 through 12
overall what Micah was referring to was he was accusing people
in the marketplace of cheating other
buying and selling of using these
Wicked scales.
So think about this if they could sell you a bushel of
corn.
That that was using a bushel that
was only actually nine tenths of a bushel. You
couldn't really tell the difference.
But they still charge you three bucks for that bushel, right?
And so what they get is they get to have some extra income
out of that deal.
You could do the same thing with weights on a scale which is not they
didn't have cash registers, right so they had to weigh things out
that this was three shekels of silver to buy
this item and they would put a three and a half
shekel weight on the other side.
And you had to balance it out because you don't know that
that's not three shekels.
And you had to to find a little bit
more income a little bit more money and put it on the scale.
But think about how evil all that is, right?
It's so evil in the sense that that this
was primarily in the marketplace the people who
were coming to buy those things from those people were primarily
poor people and so they're on the backs of
the poor. They're just getting more money. They had no
choice but to buy the food from these people and they didn't know anything
different and and they had to do it if they wanted
to eat.
But those people were just in the back just raking in more
and more and more money.
But think about it again, where did that kind of Lifestyle come from?
Where did that decision to be unethical in
your scales and to be evil in your buying and
selling where did that kind of mentality come from?
It's because they turned away from God's Micah 6:8
standard.
They had said I'm I'm gonna abandon that we're gonna do this way. They
were supposed to act justly meaning be
fair. According to God's standard. They were
supposed to love faithfulness, especially to the Covenant brothers and sisters
in the land. They were supposed to be faithful and flourishing them.
And they were supposed to walk humbly with their God following
his holy pattern for life, but they
said no.
It's not what we want.
They were committing injustices. They were
seeking their own benefit and they were not Walking With
God all of that came from turning away from God.
and his standard
but here's the thing about this especially this sin that he's talking about
specifically In this passage.
Those people were kind of in it together.
We think of the vendors in the marketplace. They
would have known that the others were doing this too. And
so they're like this guy over here is charging three and a
half ounces for that same thing. Well, if he can do it I can do it.
And if I don't he's gonna make more money than me.
So I want to so they're almost all in collusion in
this thing here.
But this is an example then of what we might call a respectable
sin.
Because honestly most people at that time those vendors especially were looking
at this like let's not that big a deal.
Well, we're just taking a little bit off the top
not it's kind of like the tax collectors. You know that they were just skimming a
little off the top not a big deal. Nobody's gonna
get hurt. We're just making a little extra money here a little spending money we need
but God in Proverbs 11:1 calls unjust
Waits on abomination.
That's a pretty strong word.
Like he says unjust Waits this idea of what they're doing. Here is
an abomination.
It's deceptive. It's evil.
And so no, we're not out here selling stuff and we're you know, all these things
and maybe you could apply that some way but but think think more
about the deception here.
We must not be okay with deception even
if everybody else is doing it. We can't
be okay with it.
If we are God's people we must be.
fleeing
things like cheating at school
But everybody else cheating at school is deceptive. It's
unjust Waits.
Unethical business practices that are just based on Greed and
you're just looking for more income.
Or you're lying to cover Your Tracks over whatever other things
or or you're working at home remotely and you're
taking advantage of that. You're being a little lazy here and there right. These
are all deceptive practices.
That God would say is turning away from him.
Now, why do we do those things?
We do those things because we're looking for something more.
We want a better grade. We want more money. We
want more time. We we have a hunger in
us that we're trying to fill with whatever
that is. But listen to what first John
says about what we should think that way he says
do not love the world or the things in the world.
If anyone loves the world the love of the father is not in him
for all that is in the world the desires of
the flesh the desires of the eyes and the pride of
life is not from the father, but it's from the world.
And the world is passing away along with
its desires. But whoever does the will of
God abides forever first, John 2:15 through
17.
See again when we turn away from the Lord to
the things of this world.
We begin to live lives of selfish deception.
Because we're looking for something we're trying to find it here or there or
here or there and we begin to deceive to get it.
We must flee that attitude Church.
Because look back Micah 6 what God says
he's about to do to the people of Judah for what they've
been doing.
Micah 6:13, I will strike you with the
Grievous blow making you desolate because of your sins.
The end of verse 16 said it I will make you a desolation. You're
inhabitants a hissing. So you shall bear the
scorn of my people he is going to
judge his people for their sins.
He said just like the northern kingdom got
it. You've abandoned my Covenant and so here's what's coming.
But when we hear judgment from God, we typically
think like Hellfire Brimstone, you know, God's gonna just destroy everything.
Notice notice here what verses 14
and 15 say about this judgment.
In the illustrate this hunger I was talking about earlier, but this is the Judgment
God is bringing on them. Look at 14 and 15
again. He says you shall eat but not be satisfied.
There should be hunger within you you shall put away but not preserve
what you preserve. I'll give to the sword you shall so but
not reap tread olives, but not anoint yourself with oil
tread grapes, but not drink wine. You see
what God is saying here.
Is that when we turn away from God's standard part
of the Judgment we receive is emptiness.
We've turned away from God's standard the Judgment he brings
into our lives in part is emptiness.
See what this passage these two verses is known as
is a it's what we call in in theological terms a
futility curse.
Where God frustrates the normal expectations
of people he frustrates the
normal order of how things would work. Well normally
bless people is reversed into a curse.
That's what you saw eating will not satisfy.
Planting will not be followed by harvesting.
Treading on grapes will not result in wine storing up things will not
produce a savings. Nothing will happen as it's
supposed to happen.
Instead of what was supposed to happen? There will
be this gnawing hunger.
inside of the people instead
everything they think would fulfill them doesn't in the
end.
It's like what Jeremiah said about?
the people's idolatry Jeremiah 2 verses 11
through 13
He says has a nation changed its Gods even
though they are no gods.
My people have changed their glory for that which
does not profit be appalled. Oh heavens at
this be shocked to be utterly desolate. There's the word desolate again
declares the Lord for my people have committed two evils.
They have forsaken me the Fountain of
Living Waters turned away from me.
And they've hewed out or dug out cisterns. Those
are big containers of water in the ground for themselves broken cisterns
that can hold no
water.
Haggai, 1:6 says something similar you have sown much
and harvested little.
You eat, but you never have enough you drink,
but you never have your fill you clothe yourselves,
but no one is warm and he who earns wages
does so to put them into a bag with
holes.
so he's saying
you might have a lot.
But you never have enough.
Is that not true of our culture today?
We have so much but we never have enough. That's what he's talking to
them about. He's saying these broken sisters you're trusting
in. It's like a leaky bucket.
Like you got a bucket with a hole in the bottom. You keep feeling it up. It keeps leaking
out keep filling it up keeps leaking right or these these bag with
holes. He's talking about like you make money you toss it in
there and it falls out the bottom in the hole. That's what he's illustrating our
idolatry.
Saying it's not worth.
It's empty.
It's unsatisfying. But listen, this is what happens.
When we seek Abundant Life in the things of this
world.
In all of these other things whether that's material things and
stuff.
Or maybe it's immaterial things like relationships or
other promotions or or things like
we seek our life in things like that.
What happens is we start to react sinfully
when those things are challenged when those things are
lost when those things are broken when those things are
attacked we start to push back and we start to fight
because that is really what we're worshiping.
James 4 says this very clearly
says what causes corals what
causes fights among you is it not this that your
passions are at War within you?
You desire and you don't have so you murder you
covet cannot obtain. So you fight and quarrel.
You do not have because you do not ask you
ask and do not receive because you ask wrongly to
spend it on your own Passions.
And so this quest for self-fulfillment.
It leads to endless dissatisfaction.
And so what do we do instead?
All of these things we're trying it's a leaky bucket. It's
an empty. It's a bag with holes. What do we searching for
if nothing else works?
Where do we turn?
Remember the Augustine quote at the beginning.
Where he said that God has made us for himself, and we
will not find rest until we find rest in
him.
There's your answer.
That's where we turn if we what we're looking for is rest.
That's where we turn we should turn to the one
who satisfies.
Turn to the one the capital o one who
satisfies.
Again, the point of this whole passage is to
reveal the futility of idols.
to reveal the foolishness of a
materialistic lifestyle
and so by implication then
God is saying to them and he's saying it to
us today.
That there is something better to choose from.
that there is something that will satisfy you
if he's saying all of this won't all of this won't all of
this won't that means there is something that will
And we need to turn over to the Gospel of John to see it.
So turn right from Micah over into the New Testament.
We're going to spend some time in the Book of John this morning as well.
John chapter 4.
Turn right few pages into the New Testament Matthew Mark
Luke, and then John.
starting chapter 4
to see where we should turn and that the reality
of this the scene setting here is that Jesus
was passing through Samaria one time
and he sits down at this well, and he meets this woman.
Samaritan woman
but I want you to see their interaction here. Look at John chapter 4 starting
in verse 7.
Really read down through verse 15 and we'll see what happens as he
meets her.
And listen for the things that we've been saying so far.
He says a woman from Samaria came to draw water.
And Jesus said to her give me a drink.
For his disciples are gone away to the city to buy food and the Samaritan
woman said to him. How is it that you a Jew? Ask
for a drink from me? A woman of Samaria for Jews
have no dealings with Sumerians.
Jesus answered her if you knew the gift of God who
it is that is saying to you give me a drink you would have asked him
and he would have given you living water.
And the woman said to him sir, you have nothing to
draw water with and the well is deep. Where do you get that Living Water?
Are you greater than our father Jacob he gave us this well and drank for
himself as did his sons and his livestock.
And Jesus said to her everyone who drinks of this water the well
water will be thirsty again.
But whoever drinks of the water that I will give him will never
be thirsty again.
The water that I give him will become in him
a spring of water welling up to eternal
life.
The woman said to him sir. Give me this water so that
I will not be thirsty or have to come here to draw water.
And so notice what Jesus was doing in the scene?
He was showing her this tangible illustration.
He was saying to her that if you keep coming back to this
well again, and again, you're still going to be thirsty.
You keep coming to that thing that you think's going to satisfy. You
have to keep returning. It will never relieve your thirst.
It's actually in here.
It's only when you drink from the living water.
Will that thirst be quenched?
And so keep that in mind and just turn one or two pages to the
right over to John chapter 6.
We'll keep that one and we're going to see something else here in John chapter
6 now. Jesus said in between these scenes, he'd
miraculously fed 5,000 people with a Hebrew Happy
Meal. He'd walked on the water. And so he's he's shown
off these big things that he's done.
And the next day after that the crowd found him and
they wanted more of what he was offering.
They were hungry, right?
You eat once this day the next day you're going to be hungry again. And so
Jesus said this John chapter 6 verse 26
Jesus answered them truly I say to you you are seeking
me not because you saw signs, but
because you ate your fill of the
loaves.
Not because you saw that Messiah was here. It's because
you're hungry.
And so Jesus flipped the script on them and instead said
this look at verse 35.
He said I am the bread of life.
Whoever comes to me shall not hunger whoever believes
in me. Shall never thirst. Now. It
sounds a lot like what he told the woman at the well, right.
So this is just right here together. Now, of course, the people are
confused by that.
Like what do you mean this bread that I'm never gonna be hungry how because their
context was that God had fed, the Israelites in
the wilderness with Manna Heavenly bread that they
had been provided for that that was their satisfaction. And
so they're thinking that as the true bread
Look at what Jesus responds to them with in
verse 48 down through 51.
He says I am the bread of life.
Your father's ate the man in the wilderness and they
died.
This is the bread that comes down from heaven. So that
one may eat of it and not die. I am the living
bread that came down from heaven. If anyone eats of
this bread, he will live forever.
And the bread that I will give for the life of the world is my
flesh.
And so check this out here here. We're tying it all together. Now with the
what Jesus said to the woman at the well in verse four about
the water and then here in chapter 6 with the people
in the bread. It's the same thing. He's that we've been saying all day
today in this sermon.
By the way, it's the same thing that the Book of Ecclesiastes says.
Which says that everything under the sun?
Everything on this Earth is limited. It's
unsatisfying you could try it all and you
still wouldn't have that void filled in your heart. And
so what it says what Jesus is saying here in
four and six of chasing after the
things under the sun that won't fulfill us.
Essentially. What we need to do is we need to get over the Sun.
And you understand that we're searching here under the
sun and none of it's gonna work. We got to get over the sun
where true life is actually hidden.
We're satisfaction is found where eternity begins Jesus
said himself John 6:27. He
says don't work for the food that perishes that bread
before that they died with but for the food that endures to
eternal life.
Which the son of man will give to you?
What he's saying again?
Nothing else will satisfy.
Even the bread from Heaven that they got in the
wilderness was not enough.
They still died. They still had to have more and more
and more.
None of it anything else is enough to satisfy
what these people needed. What we need is to
trust in the living Bread of Life come down from heaven Jesus
Christ. The one who gave his life for our
eternal life.
Again, the point of all of this.
Is to expose what happens when
we turn away from the Lord?
When we walk our own way.
When we stiff arm his leadership in our lives, this is
what happens.
It leads to destruction.
It leads to deception.
It leads to emptiness.
And I know you see it in your life. Just as much as I sit
in my life every day.
Both inside of us. We see this we feel this right but
we see it all the time around us, don't we?
Where you feel a little bit sad or down?
And so you feel that compulsion to to buy
a new book to satisfy or to go buy some new
shoes or or to go to get a new car.
So you get that new car smell again that you lost after this one's now
two years old right or or you work more hours to
pile up your 401k or
Or you you want more money? So
you're tempted to fudge the numbers on your tax return a little bit or or
to tweak that contract so it has some little claws
in it that they wouldn't find and and you can get more money
out of that.
Where you start to long for political power and so you
start berating every opposing candidate online all the time.
Or you start to feel a little bit lonely. And
so you jump online and you look or you
start to send that flirty text to that coworker. You
see these things kind of happen where you're all in an
effort trying to find your joy in something
under the sun.
Where you're finding your life, you're trying to find your life in stuff
or in relationships or in any other
thing and it only ends up worse in the end,
right?
It doesn't satisfy. You have to have more you got to find something
new. You got to move on to the neck. You see this never never
fills that Gap.
That's why Jesus said the exact opposite.
In Matthew, 16:24 and
25.
He said if anyone would come after me let him deny
himself and take up his cross and follow
me.
For whoever would save his life
meaning if you're finding your life in this if
you save your life, you're gonna lose it.
But whoever loses his life for my sake will actually
find it.
I know it's counterintuitive.
But if we want to truly live then we must lose our
lives.
We must lose our desires ourself dying
to ourself to give up control to
him. That's what Jesus said life is found.
if you don't
if you try to find your life in anything in this world and try
to search it out, if you don't give your
life to him Micah 6:16 remember what he did
to Judah says God will make you a desolation.
You shall bear the scorn of my people. He's going
to judge. That's the bad news here. If you
turn away from God's standard. He will judge you for your
sin. If you try to find your life or your love in
life, and anything else God will judge you
for that because it's never going to work.
That's the bad news of this.
And some of you are running headlong into that pathway.
That's the bad news is judgment is coming.
But that means there's good news too, right?
See the good news is that Jesus was judged
for you.
Jesus was made a desolation for you.
Jesus bore the scorn for
you.
Just listen to Isaiah 53 3
through 5 and listen to the language here. He was despised and
rejected by Men A Man of Sorrows acquainted
with grief as one from mid
hide their faces. He was despised and we
esteemed him not
Surely he is born our griefs carried our
sorrows.
We steamed him stricken Smitten by God.
and afflicted
But he was pierced for our transgressions.
He was crushed for our iniquities upon him was
the chastisement that brought us peace. And
with his wounds we are healed.
So at First Peter 2:24 says he himself bore
our sins in his body on the tree that we might
die to sin and live to righteousness.
See friend, that's where true life is found.
It's not found in stuff or in reputation or in
power or money or anything else under the
sun.
This abundant true life we're talking about this eternal
life. We're talking about is found in Jesus. The one
who came from Over the son to live
with us and die with us and resurrect for
us.
And he's coming back one day to take us home
with him where we go over the son eventually.
but listen until that day comes
remember he has made us for himself.
And we will not find rest.
Until we find our rest in him.
believer stop searching
You've got it in him already.
Stop running to all of the other things that are are clinging
to us and and attaching onto
our lives and keeping us as Hebrews says from running
the race that God's called us to run strip it
off get rid of it and stop trusting it
because you already have rest in Jesus.
rest in his presence
Remember who he is? Remember what he's done and rest in
that?
But here's how we're going to get there today.
We wanted to provide a time of Silent reflection.
over
over where we stand with that
because
in Light of Christ in light of this message from Micah
nine.
We need to reflect.
Where we feel this emptiness in
our souls.
Where do you see deception in your own heart?
Is the Lord Awakening you to any Idols that you're
chasing?
And so we want to give some space for that.
We run away from quiet. We need to rest in that for
a second sit in that quiet just to allow the Lord to to Really
confront us.
And so you're going to feel some emptiness of where you've sought this
and it hasn't fulfilled. You you're gonna feel some deception of
where you've maybe lied here or deceived here. You're gonna see some
Idols. That's what we're praying for you and you should pray for yourself that God
would expose that in your heart. And so as you feel that
as you recognize where you have not hungered after
the Lord You've hungry after all these other things.
Here can be your prayer.
Psalm 42
As a deer pants for flowing streams.
So pants my soul for you o God.
my soul thirsts for God
for the Living God
Maybe you've never felt that hunger before.
or maybe you have
covered it with all of this other stuff and you know, it's back there, but you've
never just let it actually be there.
to thirst and hunger for God
Just in this quiet moment.
Run to that father who loves you already.
And let him strip away all that other stuff.
And to feel that hunger that's only found satisfaction in
him.